hallo mein name ist luke hat meine
lieben zuschauer wie so ziemlich jeder
von uns habe auch ich damals sehr gerne
cartoons geschaut und cartoons haben so
an sich dass sie gezeichnet sind
doch und ich glaube auch so ziemlich
jeder von uns hat sich schon mal
vorgestellt wie gewisse cartoon
charaktere in real life aussehen würden
und das schauen wir uns heute mal an
losgeht
also wir sehen spezielle cartoon karte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist der spot und so könnte dann echt
aussehen
in todesangst vor dem also das könnte
thaddäus in real life seien die nächste
person ist denn ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
habe nie wärme liga oder so geguckt ich
weiß nicht mehr ob er wirklich aus
family guy ist das hier ist der ist ich
weiß auch nicht ob der aus family geist
ich hab das nie geguckt du mir leid aber
das hier ist die nächste person mein
gott deutschen der serie so voll süß und
so könnte der ein echt aussehen
auch vor dem würde ich eher weglaufen in
real life lilo & stitch habe ich mega
gern geguckt früher ich war auch in
diesem kinofilm damals im kino
das ist die nächste person und zwar dass
arnold man muss wirklich mal sagen also
ich habe jetzt herr arnold auch nie
richtig gesucht aber guckt euch mal das
an das ist die gezeichnete person und
das hier ist die personen in real life
animiert dk das ist übel gut
nachgestellt also ich finde es wirklich
alles sehr sehr gut gemacht und die
haben es mega auf den punkt getragen
oh mein gott
hal
ja
krank als oma ist bisher wirklich mein
absoluter favorite von allen also der
ist wirklich perfekt getroffen
roma war besser aber vor allem die haare
sind sehr gut gelungen also jetzt hatten
wir hopper von simpsons und bat hatten
wir auch von den simpsons machen wir
weiter mit der nächsten version des
grand parade als auch von den simpsons
also ab und wir sehen auch schon hier
das ist einfach mega kraß wieder auch
mit der brille und den augen
vor dem er dich auch angst und real life
also dieser basis sieht ja komplett
creepy aus ich habe keine ahnung wer das
genau ist butt head bin ich auch ganz
ehrlich habe ich auch keine ahnung von
wer das ist ich weiß nicht ob ich diese
ganzen serien nicht empfangen konnte
weil ich kein ende am 1
ey
das ist bert in der serie und so
todes creepy aus also bisher habe ich
wirklich am meisten angst vor
mit dem switch & bert also dieser berg
sieht echt mega crazy aus buzz lightyear
sieht auch sehr gut aus aber habe ich
auch wirklich nie geguckt ich war auch
nie in dem kinofilm das ist charlie oh
mein gott er sieht eins zu eins aus wie
die gezeichnete zeichnung
gezeichnete zeichnung also charlie wird
wirklich auch sehr sehr gut nachgestellt
werde dargestellt
okay ich habe eine neue person würde
also das kuki monster sieht ja komplett
furchteinflößend aus alten ein gottfried
flintstones messers fred feuerstein da
wo man selber nachdenken über dann dumme
fragen das hier ist frieda aus dragon
ball habe ich auch nie richtig geguckt
muss ich auch ganz ehrlich gesagt zu
geben
das hier ist frei aus der serie ich habe
keine ahnung haben auch nicht
[Applaus]
der sieht bisschen aus wie bernd das
brot also spongebob ist auch mega gut
gelungen finde ich es sieht zwar ein
bisschen anders aus als in der serie
aber er ist natürlich auch sehr schwer
darzustellen haben das hier ist jake das
finde ich sehr sehr schlecht aber es ist
schlussendlich auch irgendwie ein hund
der eine gezeichnete wir dürfen jessica
rabbit die kennt man aus der serie keine
ahnung nach jessica rabbit kommt luigi
der ist auch sehr sehr gut gelungen aber
es ist halt ehrlich gesagt einfach nur
sonne die kostüme also das sieht man
auch an karneval hier in köln oft leute
mit rumlaufen im mai mario genau
dasselbe das ist auch einfach ein kostüm
und nach mario kommt jetzt mit ihm aus
und es ist es ist einfach ne maus
er hat nicht mal die schuhe an auch
nicht die hose ist es einfach einfach
eine mauer als nächstes haben wir nach
micky maus und den charakteren ist ab 1
sogar mit den muttermalen und der glatze
da oben ist das richtig gut geworden
also bisher bin ich von allen simpsons
nachstellungen mega begeistert route
unser super sind auch gut aber sieht
auch eher so aus als wenn das halt
einfach irgendwelchen normalen kinder
werden die da eben
[Musik]
was ich persönlich sagen dass ich sandra
als patrick besser gefunden hätte handel
statt was soll ich will jetzt endlich
beenden meine lieben freunde werde ich
meine reaktion auf einige charaktere
läuft gefallen hat dass und in ein
darunter die medien schreiben ja mal
gerne und in die kommentare
welcher cartoon charaktere mir leid euch
am besten gefallen hat
von denen die ich euch heute gezeigt
habe und ihr könnt mir zudem auch mal
gern und in die kommentare schreiben
ob ich eventuell in einigen tagen
nochmal auf cartoon charaktere als ein
mensch reagieren soll also das haben
beispielsweise pikachu ein mensch ist
und dass spongebob als mensch wenn ihr
das wollt dann abonniert kanal oder wenn
ihr schon ab und dann kriegt gerne auf
die glocke es ist kostenlos und dadurch
verpasste keine videos mehr bekommt eine
benachrichtigung wenn nicht was neues
hoch laden und jetzt kommt auch das auto
[Musik]